[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today he is the host of a brand
new book that will be coming out in just
about a month here from paycheck to
purpose it is on sale now the clear path
to doing work you love it's in pre-sale
you can check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
we're just talking going on the air it's
breaking all kinds of records from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love so if you want to
talk about career you want to talk about
getting a job
you want to talk about your money your
life we are here to help the call is
free and some say it's worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five john is in
milwaukee hey john welcome to the ramsay
show
hey uh it's so good to be here i'm a
longtime listener first time caller
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
oh yeah this is a question really for
ken um so for the past year i've been
working as a freelance photographer
i really thought i was clear about what
i wanted to do but i'm i'm really having
some doubts here
what are you doubting specifically
um so i i work in freelance as a real
estate photographer
and so the past of maybe six months have
been really challenging because
um essentially
the uh the market of course is so hot
and crazy and uh it you know you could
sell a house in your sleep essentially
and uh so i've really been struggling to
kind of make it happen and i think just
really dealing with like imposter
syndrome as well just like man there's
there's so many other photographers in
the area and things like that um and i
really thought i was clear so when you
say you're struggling to make it happen
meaning uh because houses are moving so
quickly people don't need photographers
and your work is dried up is that what
i'm hearing
correct yeah well so let's just remove
that for a second and i know that's hard
but suspend some reality for just a
moment if you were rocking and rolling
right now as i'm assuming at least
you've been much busier than you are now
would you be calling me with doubt and
imposter syndrome
oh probably not no so what we have to
look at is it is your circumstances
it is your
current season
that is causing all of the doubt and by
the way that's very natural so give
yourself a break there's nothing wrong
with you
you shouldn't feel bad about it but
you're just facing some good old tough
times and when times get tough we start
to doubt ourselves because we start
looking at all of the other things
instead of the reality which is because
of these circumstances in this market
you're having a tougher time but the
reality is is when you got into
photography and picked up a camera for
the first time you wanted to take
pictures and you haven't lost that juice
for being artistic and creative in that
way true or false
uh true okay so great so what we do is
we say is it always going to be this way
are these uh real estate circumstances
in this current market are they always
going to be this way yes or no
no no
uh are you still creative whether or not
you're shooting real estate pictures or
not
yes or no oh yeah of course yeah so uh
photographers have to hustle you gotta
get out there so
my overall advice to you is
understand that what you're experiencing
right now is good old-fashioned
uh tough times that create doubt get
clear and i just helped you kind of
re-establish for a moment what you
believe about photography and what you
love to do and why you love to do it so
start taking pictures of everything else
there's a lot of things you can take
pictures of if you've got to go work a
side hustle for a season just to stay in
the game then that's what you do but do
not quit this you will regret it if you
walk away from being a photographer i
got lost in your story arc just a second
ago um
did you ever make a living doing this
uh no it's a side hustle that i uh
decided to make full time uh last year
at exactly a long time okay
so yeah i mean not your fault but that's
just the way it worked out thank you to
pandemics and so forth the um
um so when you were in the side hustle
what kind of money were you making
um
it was less than 20 000
uh and what have you made now that it's
full time and times are tough
uh
even less than that yeah i'd say yeah
all right yeah so it's still a side
hustle but we don't quit i mean we do so
you got one or two options you can
backfill
the hard times
with a uh and make it a side hustle
again with a new with a new gig that's a
temporary gig it's gonna be two years
three years you're gonna work a job
while you build this thing back up you
get back get your feet back under you
because you got the wind knocked out of
you um
because you jumped at exactly the wrong
time like they moved the freaking boat
right as you jumped you know i mean
somebody hit the gas on it and you know
that kind of thing it wasn't your fault
but it's like a bad trick you know a
cosmic jokester so uh the the other
option is that you can look at it your
business model and go okay real estate
is
and i hey i got my real estate license
in 1978.
john
this is the weirdest market i have ever
seen
i'm telling you i mean it's a weird it's
got so many components to it elements to
it that are just
strange so you know is it going to last
that way absolutely not it's just an
anomaly
and so uh it's not status quo it's not
predictable into the future it's not
that kind of stuff so having said that
you either you either backfill with a
full-time gig like you used to do
and go get a similar job like you used
to have just as a you know and say i'm
gonna do this for two three years get my
feet back under me let this market
stabilize and then re-enter or you pivot
with the photography and go i'm gonna
take pictures of stuff other than houses
and try to add some things to your
product line
that is happening right now uh kids
sports
i had a friend that made a bazillion
dollars taking little league
sport picture oh it's the easiest sale
in the history of the world sport
picture hey parents you want a picture
with your kid
the only problem you got is there's
other people doing it but i mean it's
just well yes sure it is i mean and
action photos
of a six-year-old playing soccer i mean
it's amazing so
i don't know i'm just making stuff up
here but that camera can point at things
other than just houses yeah you got to
diversify but the big thing is is you
don't quit you know it's like he called
and said i thought i was clean
you didn't you didn't know you were
clear you absolutely still you just had
you you know just like some of the stuff
i launched last year uh my timing sucked
your timing sucks okay i got some stuff
that i just assumed last year hadn't
occurred uh i'm trying to forget it as
dr john deloney would say i'm recovering
i'm recovering from trauma yeah so thank
you very much all right yeah stephen is
with us stevens in albuquerque new
mexico hi stephen how are you
hey dave it's an honor to talk with you
you too how can we help
well uh buddy and i are students and
we're thinking to start a small
consulting business together until we're
done with school
and uh well the more i've looked into it
seems like starting a business with
sewing can involve
some challenges you know kind of like
getting married yeah so uh my question
for you guys is what are some things
that the two of us need to discuss ahead
of schedule to make sure we're a good
fit and on the same page to do this
together it's a wonderful question and
i've got a pretty thorough answer that i
want to give you in more than 10 seconds
because i have a commercial bearing down
on me i have to make money around here
because ken coleman likes to get paid
so it's all my fault it's all your fault
so there you go anyway we'll be back
from this commercial break and we will
make sure
that we talk you through how to deal
with this idea this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at ch
ministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
from paycheck to purpose is ken
coleman's new book the clear path to
doing work you love there's a get hired
bonus pack i get promoted bonus pack you
can choose between the two all for
twenty dollars you get over a hundred
dollars worth of stuff it's on pre-sale
right now at
ramseysolutions.com we're talking to
stephen in albuquerque new mexico coming
out of school got his buddy they want to
both be consultants they're talking
about doing it together
and he heard a rumor that that might be
troubling like a bad marriage
uh so what kind of consulting are you
going to do stephen
uh we're thinking of partnering with
local high schools and helping students
apply for scholarships
okay
either one of you ever done that
well we both
have a lot of experience applying for
scholarships and successfully getting
them
so we think we're a good fit for uh for
helping people that are kind of new to
that sort of thing
okay all right
um
all right
uh
what's the business model how's that
gonna have you guys figured out how
you're gonna charge is it parents is it
school systems paying you what's the
model
so the basic model is going to be two
tiers we're going to have one opening
tier where we provide introductory
videos where
parents or schools can pay to access the
videos where we provide basic stuff and
then if folks want to move up and meet
with us one-on-one you know we'll offer
that too if you know if they're in our
region
okay
all right well let me start with the
premise that i operate on and that is
the only ship that won't sail as a
partnership
so i would urge you to try to figure out
a way to do this as
uh a joint venture rather than a
partnership because what typically
happens
in all the years i've done business
coaching i find almost
zero
i mean it's not quite but it's almost
zero businesses one decade later are
still partners
the exception is by far the the notable
exception is medical partnerships in law
firms but short of that the the typical
two guys that go start into doing
something and what normally happens is
one of you works harder than the other
one of you has better ideas than the
other one of you makes more sales than
the other one of you is more personable
or more talented than the other and it
can be you it can be switching places
like one of you is more talented and the
other one works harder and so they you
end up there there's this resentment
thing that builds up and you don't feel
like the other guy's carrying his weight
and uh it runs into all kinds of crap
if you are going to and so i would try
to figure out a way to say okay
uh i'm going to go over here and do this
set of schools you go over here and do
that set of schools we'll compare notes
we'll help each other uh we'll encourage
each other but that set of schools is
your money this set of schools is my
money and even if we create a video
product together that we share the cost
on
when i sell the videos in my schools i
make money when you sell the videos in
your school you make money and just kind
of keep it very separate like a joint
venture rather than a full-on
partnership
i'm going to challenge you to do that
that's what i want you to do because i
think you're going to make a mess if you
don't but if you ignore that here's
still some guidelines all right
you need to get an attorney believe it
or not i i don't want to tell you to do
that but you need to draw up a detailed
partnership agreement
and it has to address all of the evil
d's
everything that's bad is going to happen
just about begins with a d
drug use
disinterest
default one of you walks away and wants
to own half of it while the other one
keeps working
that's default right
disability
death
what happens then you now own
half
of a scholarship business with his mom
and dad because that's his heirs because
he's not married what a dadgum mess
you know and so you've got to address
every one of the possible negative d's
disability death divorce
drug use uh uh default disinterest i
just don't want to do this anymore i'm
gonna walk away and go i'm gonna go get
a job we're not making enough money but
i'm still gonna be pissed at you when
you're successful later yeah um and so
all of that kind of crap and so you
gotta deal with every possible exit
scenario
and most of them begin with a d and you
need to do that in writing in a
partnership agreement before you begin
and i probably would not put it in the
form of a general partnership which
leaves you up in all kinds of financial
liability i'd put it in the form of an
llc but it still functions
as a partnership and i'm still going to
tell you to figure out a different way
to do it yeah and i i would i would add
too i think that's absolutely brilliant
advice i would not even think about
starting a business i liked your idea
i'm going to edit it a little bit on the
idea of you take one school system in
this county
you take the other let's see if we can
prove this thing before we actually
either one of us thinks about a business
let's prove this model first i like that
approach and then the other thing is i
was i'm curious to know if you've got a
situation where maybe steven's more the
sales guy
uh more of the you know okay this is the
handbook on how to get scholarships and
maybe the other guy's more video related
and we don't know that but in that
situation instead of a true partnership
maybe one of you is like okay you're the
video product producer i pay you
and they work together but it's not even
a joint venture that's a way to do it as
well and the other option is
um just one of you own it that's right
and then pay the other one hey and the
other one can make a percentage of
profits as their income that's right but
they're not the owner that's right when
i sell is anything with two heads is a
monster i agree
so if one was the video specialist the
idea here is is that he gets paid a
percentage on every course you sell but
it's your company and he's your
production it's like a contractor yeah
there's something that we seek out
stephen that i want you to avoid
because it's a it's a
it's a it's a it's mythology
it's a lie
and
that um
there's comfort
in doing things with other people
and not feeling like the lone ranger
there's comfort in you and your buddy
doing
locking arms and working on stuff
together there's comfort when ken and i
work together on launching ken's book
yeah and then when we add to that an
entire team around us there's a lot more
comfort
to that because it's not you know it's
not good that man be alone and and um so
you feel
more invincible
more strong more courageous when you
have your
you know your guy next to you and and
you confuse that comfort with the need
to do a partnership it can be an
employee employer relationship yes
absolutely and you can pay him zero
salary
only a percentage of profits and the
part that he brings to the table is x y
and z and you bring a b and c
and one of you probably had more of this
idea of turning this into a business
than the other one did that's right and
just because you both want to win that's
what dave's saying is so beautiful just
because you both want to win doesn't
mean we have to
both be in it together in the same exact
role yeah i think you're right dave that
comfort can turn into contention pretty
quickly if they don't focus on those ds
almost always almost always yeah
yeah yeah yeah you should you should
well all right let's see here damon is
in topeka kansas hey damon what's up
how are you dave great man how can we
help just it's an honor to speak with
you okay dave i will be brief um i
basically want to know what you would do
in my situation i want to know what dave
ramsey would do
day march of this year
i became completely debt free i paid off
my house after living in it nine years
and 10 months good for you i have no
debt thank you
and i became engaged i got well i got
engaged in april
and the problem the circumstance is my
daughter my girlfriend her fiance has a
daughter
who's a sophomore in high school and
she's heavily involved with activities
so
transferring
to another school is not an option
my the distance from my house to her
high school was about 15 to 20 miles
i made a suggestion to my fiancee give
me a year
she has some dad also she has she bought
she bought her house three years ago
and she has 16 000 in debt
so i made a suggestion to her
to give me a year to get my house ready
for to sell
save up enough money that way when she
marries or we get married excuse me
i'd pay off with debt because that
becomes awesome does it take a year to
fix up your house is it that dumpy
no it's not but i might i was wanting to
save up
enough money to pay off her debt oh and
what's your housework
200 000 well what would be wrong with
just selling it
i can sell it yeah and then move over in
that other neighborhood and buy one and
pay cash for it
okay you could do that couldn't you okay
how old is it what year of school is
this kid in
the sophomore
yeah i mean
you're making a lot of decisions here
for something for two years of this
kid's life
so but you may be moving again but i
mean you can sell it and sell her house
and pay off all her debt and put the
money together that's left and buy a
house with it for cash
i think that's probably what we're doing
it's just starting over let's wipe the
slate clean and get a fresh start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brock and nelly are with
us hey guys how are you dave it's great
to be here well we're honored to have
you where do you all live
well we're on the go we just left bethel
connecticut we just sold our house and
we're on the move where are you moving
we're going to vancouver
for about a year yeah new job by way of
nashville all right i like it got some
family here so we're hanging out just
swing by and see us well thank you man
so how much that have you guys paid off
hundred thousand all right
love it how long did that take 34 months
it's a little interesting 32 months if
you count when we got uh severance i
lost my job oh that's sweet we held on
to the severance for a little bit and
then we kind of considered that our
debt-free moment but we waited till we
paid which is about two months later wow
34. yeah oh so in the last two months
you lost your job not the first two
uh we lost it in
after 32 months of doing it 32 months is
when we got the notice and then we just
okay until i got a new job is at the end
of the story not the beginning okay yeah
all right and so what was your range of
income not counting all that mess but i
mean yep through from uh during the 34
months started off with your program at
around 83 000 and then uh started side
hustling um i got a second job teaching
animation and so now we're around 106.
all right very good and so today you're
an animator yeah and a teacher event
animation that's correct and what do you
do nelly i am a stay-at-home mom and
also a homeschool mom i love it very
good good for you guys well done so what
kind of debt was the 100 000
student loans yes wow
some smaller no some credit cards little
ones uh we had one bank loan and a
second mortgage loan down payment loan
yeah okay pretty normal
all right wow wow wow wow well what got
you started on this almost three years
ago actually uh i had observed a really
close friend of mine uh tyler k cat at
my studio where i worked as an animator
he was an animator too and him and his
wife samantha were working really hard
on your baby steps and i remember
specifically a meal where all of us went
out to eat and he pulled out his little
lunch and it was like a pbj or something
and i'm spending 22 bucks on like a
pizza yeah and i just watched them and
watched their their hard work their
sacrifice their obedience and i wanted
that
and so when watching disciplined people
is inspiring oh yeah yes i don't care
what it is whether it's somebody that's
losing weight you know or whatever
somebody's you know they're finishing
their degree
whatever it's inspiring to watch
somebody pay a price to win
so that was it and then the tipping
point for us when we decided it was time
uh is when i was sitting in the car and
i had a tax return check and it was the
same as baby step one plus our smallest
loan
and i was like i want this to last
because it just disappears so quick yeah
i'm just tired of it so i turned on your
show and i reached out to tyler my
friend and i who's here they're here
today
yeah they're supporting us right there i
reached out to him and started asking
questions and they lent us your book the
total money makeover and that was there
it is it just took off came on yep
and so you're busting all the way along
you get all you got the finish line in
sight you can see the yellow tape and
the job goes
yeah we were getting so close we were on
track and then the job went and this is
the cool part of the story is um
i told my wife i was like i'm my plan is
not working for our family
i can't i'm not doing this right so i
want to see what god's going to do
and so
he's a bit of a show off
he is if you go back to when i was 19.
the whole thing you think she's god no
we went back to when i was 19 and i had
started working for a company that
parent company i ended up working for
again later so when i lost my job they
counted all those years of service so my
severance was the amount we needed to
pay off our debt oh my god it was just
just like that and then you held on to
it till you get the next gig yeah which
is what you should do you should push
pause yeah in the middle of a storm yeah
covid and yeah and then you then then
you get the next gig and and here we go
okay ready to go and we sold the house
oh there's that too yeah so you know we
lost we lost a lot it was a year of
change and loss
but it was the best time to sell the
house too so there's some silver lining
in there some other blessings as well so
we're trying to look at those
well and and it's all up from here man
that's so cool well done that's
impressive it is impressive so i got to
know since since your buddies here did
you start eating pb and j once you
committed to this oh yeah i i started i
created my own uh and i lost a lot of
weight and i was like you know i made
like these pizzas out of tortilla shells
and i ate them like every day yeah yes
every day aldi's
all three 14 years of tortilla pizza oh
yeah that was our aldi's was our main
place we discovered how great it was for
our budget and yeah every dollar and
groceries is what killed us so we that
saved us when we switched where'd it go
gosh that was awesome that's so fun how
does it feel now that you're free i have
a cool story about that i didn't i
didn't know what had happened uh i we
had received the payment for the house
the money we got from the sale and i was
telling tyler over the phone was like i
just didn't i saw the number and i was
like cool
but if you had gone back three years ago
i would have been like oh thank the lord
like i need this
so i was like i think i don't care and
he goes no no you have peace
i was like oh man
yeah this was good i like this that's
what it is we're not desperate i haven't
had that feeling before i didn't know
what it was
we believe we can make everything work
on small numbers because we've done it
and god god has given us everything we
need
so everything else is meant to overflow
to others and so that's where we're
headed
nelly what was the hardest part for you
i'm the free spirit in this relationship
so
knowing that we're gonna have a budget
was really hard for me in the beginning
but in my gut i knew that the lord was
pressing something upon our lives and i
should just trust him and follow that so
i think trusting and knowing that a
budget is a good thing was really hard
for me so did you get a voice in the
budget and that gave you more comfort
or did he just tell you what it was
no he actually gave me a little bit of
spending it's called the miscellaneous
sync fund okay every month just for mama
to stay sane just for a little bit okay
nelly sanity fund yeah it's a good one
you need to have a line item for that
yeah i like it like you know why do this
debt-free journey with your spouse if
they're not going to be there at the end
that's a good that's a really it's an
interesting insight yeah
wise man
[Laughter]
so nelly i gotta ask you because i think
this is really great a great
relationship story here how long did it
take for you to then acclimate to this
and go okay
now i'm in i've got the sanity part now
i'm convicted and i'm all in
i think after our first vacation
we were two weeks before our key west
florida vacation
and he dropped the bomb but we need to
have a budget for this vacation and i
was like you did you did not but he did
and and during this vacation i realized
we did not have a financial fight not
one
i could get macarons and we have a
budget for that
you know that was nice yeah for the
first time i didn't feel any tension
after purchasing something
so having that freedom was sauce sounds
like rachel
[Music]
because i've heard a story about rachel
and her vacation
yeah
it's that permission to spend yeah
that's what it is a budget is right he's
never done that before i never thought
of it that way so that was that was
probably the biggest thing for us was
discovering we're actually very free
with a budget very good that's cool good
for you guys i'm very very proud of you
thank you well done
congratulations and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages good
laila
seven lincoln six and leona who's three
all right very fun
good good well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you you've obviously
changed your legacy and your whole
family tree congratulations thank you
and another copy of the total money
makeover because time to give that to
somebody so they can get started and
that way you can pay it forward and
we'll we'll start that for you so
congratulations you guys very proud of
you good looking family it's awesome
stuff a hundred thousand dollars paid
off in 34 months making 83 to 106 brock
nelly layla lincoln and leona count it
down let's hear a debt-free screen three
two
one
[Applause]
you know who the second happiest guy in
the room is
his friend who got him to do it oh no
questions
great legacy there way to go man that's
pretty cool how about the kiddos dave
they crushed it yeah they were
practicing yeah that had been rehearsed
well done
and you know what they may remember it
too i think hey their family changed
their life
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
home school parents we know that
preparing your teen for the real world
can feel like a really big job
does for all parents and teaching them
complicated money topics like compound
interest taxes insurance and don't get
in debt but you can do it our homeschool
curriculum can help foundations in
personal finances helped over 5
million students learn the money lessons
that they need to thrive now and down
the road this homeschool curriculum has
all of the lesson plans video content
and activities already created
giving you some well needed time back
in your day text homeschool
233 789
to learn more about our life-changing
personal finance curriculum for middle
and high schoolers text home school to
3378
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
even if you mismeasure or you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from melissa in
alabama i'm 35 years old i've worked at
a major corporation for 10 years and
advanced my career to a very comfortable
financial spot however this role has
been physically and mentally draining
since covid
i'm grateful for the job and the
benefits however i'm extremely unhappy
my husband is also starting up a side
hustle and i'm building my own business
doing something that fills my cup we are
selling our rental home and i plan on
taking a 12 month sabbatical from my job
to build our businesses we would rely on
the profit from the rental sale to
offset my income should we be investing
the sale proceeds
instead of using them this way or does
happiness and quality of life outweigh
investing
well
brother the way this question is set up
it's almost impossible for my queen yeah
question
i i suppose does happiness matter yeah
no come on the baby steps in the
financial plan that we teach at ramsey
solutions is what matters so assuming
the sabbatical means you can return to
the job in 12 months and that you do
regardless of how much you grow this
business and you don't go backwards in
the financial plan that we teach the
baby steps then sure but there's so much
in here that's unknown and up for
opinion and up for emotion
it's really really hard to delineate an
answer there with all that's being
presented but don't go backwards
not for me it's not
i can i can cut right through this crap
um
the um
here's the deal
when you you were doing just fine until
you couch it at the end
uh does happiness and quality of life
outweigh investing that they are not
mutually exclusive kiddo you can
actually do both
and so here's the thing
you are just sick and tired of this job
well so suck it up for until you can get
your side hustle up and running
you keep working until you get your side
hustle up and running
you get it up and running when you get
it up and running and get some money
coming in then you can afford to quit
you quit
but you don't burn off the rental
property
on a on the false doctrine the fight the
fatalistic premise that somehow you have
to trade money for happiness that's
absolute horse crap
okay you're just pissed off you're
you're scared you're tired whatever's
going on over this place you're working
and you do need to exit that place but
you need to tap the brakes and exit it a
little bit slower and get your dadgum
side hustle up and running and um
but you just you just put too much drama
on here you just really did uh you're
not gonna die
nothing's nobody's trying to kill you
you're okay
you just don't like it anymore you've
been there 10 years and suddenly you
have to hit eject and shoot into the
stratosphere just calm down a little bit
get your side hustle going use all of
the dissatisfaction that you have as
fuel for your energy to work a lot of
extra hours on this side hustle work
like a maniac for six to 12 months get
that side hustle money coming in and
then
then you can quit and you don't have to
sell the rental to pull that off that's
just if you want to sell the rental
that's fine but don't sell the rental
and then burn the money at the altar of
happiness that's absolute bs
it's overplayed sorry
i've been in situations where i'm
disgusted too and it took me a while to
dig out of the manure but it takes a
while to shovel when there's a full
truckload of it so just shovel kid
shovel you'll be all right
god i'm getting old and angry it's just
just grouchy
no i just grabbed i don't disagree with
what you're saying i think there's
there's so much more i'd love to know on
this particular question and you're kind
of yeah but i agree with what you're
saying that's definitely an option i
just don't want to see somebody go
backwards financially because they want
to grow the side hustle faster there's
no reason to there's no reason it's not
and the side hustle is unproven oh well
yeah it's we don't even know what it is
i mean my goodness would 12 months even
grow it just what about me
yeah
there's no guarantee that a 12-month
sabbatical gets the business where you
want it to there's no guarantee the
business ever gets there exactly so
that's why there's a
very interesting question yeah yeah but
it's just
what happens is
that people they're they build up we all
do this
but it requires some adult yeah maturity
to work our way past it i'd do it too
sure no different than her i'm a drama
queen too
and so
you you build up this apex this
frustration and it reaches a boiling
point and then when you hit that top a
switch flips
and you're just ready to do anything you
get away from it
you just like you know it it was a slow
climb to get there but once you're there
it's like
whatever it takes i got to get away from
this situation because this situation is
driving me bananas and unless you're in
danger yes
you know or or there's an ethics problem
or i mean something extreme you know all
it is is just frustration reached a
boiling point yes i agree and i do it
all the time i do too i i you know i go
along go along go along go along go
along go along and then all of a sudden
i'm done yes
and i have to stop and go wait a minute
that didn't happen suddenly that's right
that's in my head i loved your analogy
of the eject button that's really that's
really strong because it's like we only
hit eject when death is certain if we
don't get out right or extreme financial
harm is what you're pointing and so
sometimes we feel eject but it's not
really eject yeah
but i mean it's yeah
okay
rob is with us rob is going to help me
get out of this rob's in orlando hey rob
how are you
i'm scared how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my wife and i um we're currently in
baby set baby step six with the goal to
pay off our mortgage good for you um
getting ready to celeb getting ready to
thanks uh my mary way up uh for sure um
we're getting ready to celebrate our
sixth year anniversary this weekend we
we're we currently have about 213
000
left on the mortgage it's got an
interest rate of 4.375 percent um and we
are paying extra to do that but we've
also got um some um
non-retirement investments some about 12
000 in individual mutual funds and about
32 and a half
in individual stocks from my wife's
employee stock purchase program that
goes back about 20 years that she bought
at the beginning of her career with the
company she's with when where did you
learn the uh where did you learn the
baby steps
uh from my wife and from you
okay but starting with her the essence
of the baby steps begins at baby step
uh one and that is where you sell
everything
that is non-retirement and you apply it
to the baby steps baby step one is three
to six months uh i mean baby step one is
one thousand dollars two is debt free
three is three to six months of expenses
four is you start putting 15 of your
income into retirement five is kids
college and six is pay off the house and
so until you have done those things you
wouldn't have these other investments
still intact and so
i would have had you sell them when you
started the whole process uh but you're
so you're late in the game but let's go
and sell them now and apply them to the
house
so the challenge that we have on the
employee stock purchase shares is there
so long ago that like we moved it all to
our our smartvestor pro
but the base price for the purchase
price for those shares didn't transfer
over because something about this the
company that was holding them before it
was before the date
that they're
you're just gonna have to get some kind
of a ruling to establish a basis
you have to establish a basis but that
doesn't mean you can't sell them
you've got to somehow establish a basis
for tax purposes you're going to have
some taxes on it's what you're saying
but oh well
do it anyway
let's get the house paid off as quick as
we can all non-retirement investments
apply to the baby steps all the way up
i'm not sitting there with 200 000 worth
of stock or 10 000 worth of stock well i
got a mortgage should have been put on
the mortgage that's what i'm doing with
it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com slash survey or
text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ken's new book
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love is on pre-sale it
will be coming out in a month or so and
we have it on pre-sale with this is an
unusual offering we always offer a lot
of goodies with a book when we have it
here on pre-sale they usually give you
about a hundred dollars worth of bonus
items when you buy a 20 book early
because we want you to buy it early
because it helps us helps ken helps the
best seller list and you get a deal
because you get all this stuff so we
brought we bribe you
in this case we've got two possible ways
to bribe you that's pretty cool get
hired bonus pack which is the ebook the
audio book ken coleman's get hired
digital course ken coleman's resume
templates the one live stream access
from paycheck to purpose live event and
the ramsey plus extended 30-day trial
and all of this is uh gosh it's close to
200 worth of stuff and they get promoted
bonus pack is very similar but it also
has the ramsey disk assessment and uh
the live stream access as well and the
ramsay plus extended so check all this
out at ramsey plus or at i'm sorry at
ramseysolutions.com in the store if you
want to get a great deal on ken
coleman's book and if you really want to
get a great deal go ahead and
pre-purchase that
and pre-purchase
uh christy wright's new book take back
your time
and you get both of them and you're
going to spend like 40 bucks for two
books and you're going to get like 500
worth of stuff when you do that between
the two of them it's a great deal right
now and christy's book's going to come
out very quickly here and just about
done so you the special's just about
done on it so you don't want to miss out
on all that all of that to say we're
here to talk to you about your life your
money your career
ken is here to help you with that triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five tim is in pittsburgh hi tim
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave uh really happy to be speaking
with you today you too what's up
all right so hey um i just got a new job
um
uh it's my second one out of college i'm
doing pretty good
um they're offering to give me a company
car uh and i went ahead and accepted it
uh
i'm asking you today if i should sell my
old one or if i should keep it kind of
for a while because i'm a relatively new
employee
what is the old car
the old car is a 2018 ford focus
so it's worth five grand
oh
um i i looked up the blue book um the
blue book on it's about eleven thousand
oh it's more than okay all right okay
and what are you making
um uh so i'm making uh seventy thousand
is it the
no not yet oh what's it what's what do
you owe on the car
i owe about 8 500 on it sell it
okay okay that was easy okay so you have
yeah you 3500
3 500 bucks in your pocket if the world
blows up go buy you a 3 500 car
that's kind of what i was thinking my
parents had told me hey maybe you should
hang on to it for another couple months
and and i was saying you know i i really
do not want to have this
uh the the payments on it and then the
insurance and everything where the the
company car i'm allowed to use for my
personal miles and they pay for
everything so i'm like this is this is a
simple answer and it's a better car than
a ford focus too
oh yeah
yeah this is called a blessing yeah this
is great yeah exactly that's what that's
what i thought yeah you're you're good
good call tim i think you could have
made a good you made a good decision sir
i'm glad we could confirm it
keith is in carbondale illinois hey
keith what's up
hey dave and ken how are you guys doing
today better than we deserve what's up
so
we've been doing airplane for quite a
while but unfortunately before we
started that my wife attended a private
college back in 2006
where she took out about a 60 000
private student loan that her father
co-signed on which we obviously know now
that that was a horrible idea
um in 2008 her parents filed for
bankruptcy and then that sent her a loan
into default and ever since then there's
been no payments that have been made
towards that student loan it's been kind
of floating around ever since
um a couple weeks ago
she got a letter from a credit company
and they now said that her loan is uh 80
000 but they would be willing to settle
it for 20 000
um
so we're not sure if it's you know how
to make sure it's legit
or if we need to like go and talk to an
attorney or someone to make sure that
that's all you know
a true statement or from a you know
reputable company
they have the uh account numbers and
everything accurate
um we did ask for proof at one point and
they sent like photocopies of what the
loan looked like um and it was accurate
with
uh when she originally took it all
but they they kind of talked to us you
know in prior years but more recently
you know a couple weeks ago they offered
to settle it um
but in in the document or in the letter
the one page letter it doesn't say that
it would necessarily settle it in full
but it does say a settlement amount yeah
well that's what they do that's what
they meant but just say i need further
clarification that if you accept twenty
thousand dollars cash as settlement in
full of this debt that no nothing
further will be owed i'll accept that
i'll accept that in an email
okay and just get that in the ring that
they would sell that in full and not be
able to come back for you know anymore
later down the road exactly and the more
formal looking that document the better
but um i'm not gonna sweat it too much
it's uh it's a fairly standard practice
in that world so it's not that doesn't
smell like a scam to me at all it sounds
like a normal thing
as a matter of fact
i might counter offer
well that's why i was wondering should
we ask if they would go lower because
they offered 20. originally it was 60
now they say it's 80. yeah and we're
offering 75 percent off of the balance
so i wasn't sure if we should offer a
lesson just say you know if you can come
down a little more i think we'll do it
and just see what they say okay
and see how far and if they say no way
then do it but if they say okay well
we'll do 15. then that one sentence made
you five grand
right right okay and uh now the only the
only caveat that they did say asked to
be paid by the end of the month
and if they don't receive the payment by
the end of september that they could
challenge the terms which was a little
bit yeah well that would be normal the
offer is not you know standing forever
so have you got um
uh have you i mean have you got a way to
get the money together i don't care if
you borrow it because you're already 60
80 000 in debt and we change that out
for 15 or 20. that's a good deal so even
if you put it on a credit card i'm okay
with that
okay
yeah we've been doing the steps so we
actually paid everything else off
besides the student loans so we actually
have been kind of moving through the
steps to get to the point where you know
if they do reach out again we'll be
ready to you know oh god how much do you
have
so we have a 20 000 emergency fundraiser
oh good good we'll call them and settle
the deal man
write them a check
no electronic access to your checking
account must be in writing
that's the two rules on settling a debt
uh you're going to be taxed on the
difference there'll be a 1099-c coming
where your debt forgiveness is taxable
event and that includes private student
loans
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman's show
and author of the new book from paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five new york city benjamin
is calling hi benjamin how are you
good thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's up
so
i i drew up a product design for
um how to secure
your bicycle wheels to your bike to
protect it against theft
i have five thousand dollars on the bank
i have no debt i want to know am i in a
position to pursue it
or
and how should i also i reached out to
these companies that claim they'll help
you throughout the whole process and get
a license to manufacture i want to know
if that's a good way
to do things i mean return didn't sound
very good but i just don't know
yeah they're um
90 bs i'd stay away from them yeah um
they they uh
you know they want to help you get the
patent and they want to help you get
distribution and they want to help you
get manufacturing and they want you to
give them give them 10 or 15 000 bucks
up front and um then uh then they run
out of money and then the whole thing
doesn't happen so now i want you to got
this up from it's a what you're engaging
is a very difficult process but
they they are not your man they're not
your silver bullet
yeah
i've had the privilege to to interview
uh several founders that started
companies from scratch very very small
and now are very successful and they did
their own legwork on all of this
manufacturing
they did it all distribution they did
their own homework it had to make sense
to them i think the advice i'd give here
is what we give to people when it comes
to investing don't make a decision until
you understand it when you sit down with
one of our smart investor pros when you
sit down with manufacturers when you sit
down and learn about distribution don't
make a decision unless you understand it
don't ever take someone else's advice if
it doesn't make sense to you
you can get really really ripped off it
could be really devastating yeah so
um have you made a prototype
uh i made it but not out of the correct
materials so i can't properly test to
see if it actually protects against
theft
okay what will it take to build a
prototype
uh
i really don't know i'm guessing i'd
have to go to somebody who like pours
metal
and
she would make a mold for me and pour
one of them
could it be just done with a machine at
a machine shop
uh possibly uh
i guess so yeah it's not such a complex
piece
yeah if it could just be cut rather than
molded it'll be cheaper
um
and so uh
you might find somebody to mold it but
you're going to pay for the mold then
and here's a problem when you pay for
the mold
on a prototype
you're going to change it and the mold
is going to go in the trash
and so your mold cost just goes away
then and um
with a machine shop piece it's just a
custom made
version and it's going to go in the
trash too but you you're not throwing
away the mater the the process of
manufacturing in there the mold itself
so
it may work out i don't care if you bit
it out both ways get somebody that does
both
and and get a test on it and consider
several different materials if you can
get around a machine the reason i'm
sending a machine shop is if you can get
some guys in a machine shop who kind of
catch the vision of it and they kind of
think it's fun to work on it
they're inventors also
they invent they invent stuff every day
and so they can't keep themselves from
doing it and so they'll they'll kind of
help you
with your design and they'll go oh man
don't make it out of this kind of metal
make it out of that kind of metal it'll
it'll be lighter and it'll work better
and it'll be cheaper and they'll kind of
start it becoming your little advisor
there in the process because they'll
plug into the situation even if it's an
old crusty dude that's been doing it a
thousand years he'll have an opinion
especially that guy dave yeah
but it's harder for him to get excited
about it oh sure he's seen a thousand
thousand of these things come and go but
get and get you a prototype and then the
next step is um
and this is how this is how the folks do
it all the time and we've worked with uh
folks in entre leadership all over the
nation that have brought stuff to market
we've brought things to market not not
not bicycle stuff but
uh and not exactly the same thing but so
the next step is to
try to sell some of them off of the
prototype and get some orders for the
first run
and that'll pay for your first run
so if you could get three bike shops to
order 500 of them
or order 50 each and you so you got to
order for 150 and that might pay for
your
first 500 or whatever that you run and
oh by the way let me just tell you
two years after you start making them
it's going to look completely different
you're going to do it completely
different you're going to throw so much
crap away it's going to blow your mind
because it's going to change
it's going to morph it's going to it's
going to iterate it's going to change
and so this is going to be an adventure
for you sir
but uh but it sounds like it's something
to be fun don't spend any money you
don't have it's going to be cash
only
and pay as you go but if you can get
orders for 100 and they'll you know give
you a deposit on those orders that'll
that'll help you go to the you know a
little manufacturer and get some of them
poured or get some of them machined or
whatever it has to be done and and then
you can get going from there and there
have been people that have uh
started all kind of man i mean start
reading books on the subject you're
going to find lots of entrepreneurs
who've done exactly what you're doing oh
yeah so much information out there i
love sending them to a fabricator you
know i'm thinking these guys that are
working on cars they can fabricate all
kinds of stuff something like this and
test a test to test it
i think that's great advice dave i mean
you get it in a local bike shop only
prove that it can work now we can go and
he doesn't have to sign off thousands of
dollars to somebody who's going to make
your invention huge just run from any of
them don't don't look to get the
discovered yeah yeah yeah they're every
those ideas are a dime a dozen people
who can implement them are what are rare
yeah
and um you know somebody comes in here
and says i want to show you this idea
for ramsay to do and you have to sign an
nda and you have to do all this stuff
i'm just like you know i'm sorry i'm
busy
that's right ideas are a dime a dozen
people who can do them are hard to find
and so you're the secret sauce in this
it's not your idea
um
and you know by the way for those of you
that are don't ever get around uh
folks that work like that with their
hands i
had the pleasure growing up with them
and
and
um i i have a couple of friends that um
well i'll tell you a guy that did
exactly that
and it's a it's a
business that's hundreds of millions of
dollars is ronnie barrett yes
made the bear at 50 cal yes and he made
it in a he made a 50 cal machine gun
in
a machine shop yeah
yeah and uh now they're now they're used
in virtually every army in the free
world yeah and
every form of military in the free world
and uh but ronnie is one of those guys
that's what made me think of it is
um
he he uh is a spatial
savant he can see things in space
and see how it's going to work together
and
a lot of the guys that can can see
things in 3d uh and gals
are in these shops yes they're the ones
that can help you figure out and they'll
they'll help you shoot holes in your
design idea oh because they can see how
it works or doesn't work immediately and
they'll know that they'll know the
metallurgy and yeah which type of thing
so fabricators just a good people to
have in your quest i love watching these
custom car shows on netflix and amazon
prime where they're building these cars
from scratch and it's these kind of
people they can see stuff that no one
else can see and they can fabricate
anything and and that's that's how
you're going to do this sir so i'm
excited for you can you tell
we think you ought to go do it yeah do
it do it with cash
do it slow
don't look for a fairy godmother there's
not one that's right there's no dust
that's going to turn you and keep you
from turning into a pumpkin cinderella
you just is
and so have at it you know you just got
to gut this out you got to scratch and
claw your way through
you can do it if it's going to be done
you're going to do it if it doesn't get
done
it's you didn't do it that's where
that's what it's going to come down to
and you know that's true so many things
in our lives it is it's off to us if it
is to be it is up to me i don't know who
said it but it's been around forever
yeah
keep keep looking for a pill you can
take to get out of debt
blake thompson used to have that
commercial we had on the air called
detonal you could take this pill and get
out of this dead and all yeah
everybody's looking for a magic pill
yeah there's not a magic pill
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
author of the brand new book paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love it's on pre-sale right now with all
kinds of great deals in a bundle at
ramseysolutions.com in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
kyle and ally are with us hey guys how
are you doing good welcome where do you
live
uh brazilton georgia just north of
atlanta okay wonderful and how much debt
have you paid off a hundred and five
thousand dollars good how long did this
take uh 27 months all right and your
range of income during that time so when
we started it was right between 80 and
85 000 and then last year we finished
just under 120 000. cool what do y'all
do for a living so i'm a physical
therapist
and i'm in real estate um but my main
gig is being home with our girls that
works good gig all right love it what
kind of debt was the 105 000 uh yeah so
it was student loans a car loan and a
personal loan but the majority of that
was graduate school was physical therapy
school okay so you guys were kind of
normal he's very normal how long have
you been married
well actually today is nine years old
so you know i was like what would be
more romantic than going to ramsay
solutions and doing our debt-free
screams so you know we're happy quick
someone get the rose petals out yes
oh my god
wow i love it well i'm you know the
older you get the weirder things are
that are romantic
very cool good job you guys so uh
what got you started 27 months ago on
this journey
um so really uh the birth of our first
daughter got us started um you know i
found out i was pregnant
and
we would just have times during the
month where we would look at our bank
account and wonder where our money went
and when she was about two months old
we sat at
kitchen table and just listed out all of
our debt and we were just crushed
by the amount and just felt very
discouraged and so kyle had started
listening to the podcast
and
that really kind of pushed us to start
to follow the plan yeah so at that point
i got a second job i work
primarily outpatient orthopedic stuff
and i got a second gig at a hospital um
and at first i was working like one or
two saturdays a month but then you know
like like ali said we were kind of hit
the point where we were sick and tired
of being sick and tired so i got to
where i was working pretty much six to
seven days a week um there was one
stretch i worked 40 something days in a
row without a day off
the craziest thing i ever did was last
year during covid
the hospital i worked at had these weird
night shifts where you're sort of
screening people in the emergency room
so i would work my daytime job from 7
a.m to 4 p.m go home for a little bit
and then work at the hospital from 9 30
p.m to 5 30 a.m whoa go home take a nap
and then go back to my day time job at
eight o'clock so it's pretty pretty
crazy so we were pretty you were making
some bank doing that yes you're about to
kill yourself oh my gosh but right wow
you wanted to do that
uh so i did that
normally once a week sometimes twice a
week and did that for maybe a few months
but you know we were just really like
you said just banking up as much as we
could and uh like everything was going
towards debt so it was great wow
so uh
you you kind of emotionally hit the wall
and say this is a desperate situation it
requires desperate times and you were so
desperate that you turned on our podcast
yeah right that's good but yeah you know
um you know and during those days you
know it's hard to stay motivated it's
hard to you know go to work on saturday
and sunday and um i actually lead
worship part-time at our church so there
would be sundays where i'd go to church
lead worship go to the hospital after
that um but the the verse you guys
always quote is hebrews 12 11 you know
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but in the end it yields a harvest of
righteousness so that was something that
really um just motivated us you know
it's a short term it's not if we're
going to get out of debt it's when we're
going to get out and how fast and how
fast right so that really kept us
motivated the whole time live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else by the way if you work
like no one else later you can work like
no one else so you kind of work now like
whenever you want to
yes exactly
you're like you know you're you're just
working part-time at 40 hours exactly
right so you feel like you feel lazy
right for sure she gets she drives her
crazy because on weekends i'm like i
need to be doing something i need to be
doing
i want to ask you about those intense
work
moments let's call it a short season but
it was a season where you're really
getting after it and so when you're
physically
exhausted and your brain starts going
i don't want to do this i can't do this
where did this conviction the gazelle
intensity where did the emotion kick in
when the physical wasn't there
um yeah and i'll have ali touch in about
like our our why a little bit um if you
want to talk about that um well really
just um we couldn't get keep going
anymore we just remember our girls um we
actually had our second baby um back in
february so um we knew that we wanted to
create a good future for our kids and
that was just the biggest thing for us
and physically you know um it's kind of
amazing what the human body is capable
of doing on an hour of sleep
so you know really just
going home looking at my girls i got
three girls at home uh so you know that
really just keeps you motivated for sure
and knowing that it is a temporary
amount of time it's not i'm i'm working
80 hours a week now you couldn't do that
you thought it was a way of life exactly
right right right i guess you could but
it'd be very very it would not be very
fun
it wasn't fun anyway that's amazing
you've been preaching a little bit you
know i'm thinking of isaiah you know
when he talks about those that wait upon
the lord
will mount up on wings soar like eagles
they will run and not be weary they
shall walk enough faint you were running
but you weren't weary because of the
emotion those girls faces kept popping
up that's right for sure that's so
awesome yeah that's powerful wow
all right so now you pay off
five thousand dollars in 27 months we
know one of the secrets and lots of hard
work that's right lots of hours what are
the secrets to getting out of debt in
addition to that um lots of sacrifice
and being on the same page
and we really had to be
united um because he's gone and when
he's there he's tired
right exactly right so we we started
parenthood and then he started working
all the time so it was tough it was
really tough yeah for sure but
definitely worth it
um definitely a team effort for sure
yeah
um and just kind of fun little aside we
were actually here at money and marriage
in february of last year um right before
the world shutdown oh my god that's
right and we met rachel and took a
picture with her right here and said
we'd be back next year and we do you are
we need to do our scream all right we'll
let her know you did that for sure
very very cool well congratulations you
guys thank you outside of the two of you
who are your biggest cheerleaders
definitely our families i think they
thought we were crazy at times but they
supported us
yeah lots of uh friends and family
people at work you know saw me uh you
know working all the time and they were
kind of inspired by that and just would
kind of encourage
us as me i was going through that for
sure
and actually at the time one of my
office coordinators at my clinic that i
worked during my day job her and her
husband were going through their
debt-free journey so we would kind of
keep each other accountable and
one of the pictures i sent him was my 99
toyota 4runner 273 000 miles that's a
big part of the story because i didn't
have to get a car payment and there
would be times like man
that 2021 trd pro looks so nice
but just talk me off the ledge here so
you know uh that was a little part of
our debt free journey but yeah lots of
friends and family at work for sure
definitely so the whole method of
plugging into us was 100 of the podcast
yeah i would say we had heard of the
book obviously dave ramsey was kind of a
name growing up we grew up in church and
heard your name a lot but but the
podcast was really you hear so many
inspiring stories of people who are you
know single parents or you know they
just lost a loved one and they go
through and it's like these people can
do it
why can't we do it exactly yeah all i'm
doing is working 150 hours a week i mean
you know it's no big deal yeah
sure
wow well congratulations you two very
proud of you you're amazing people
rock star young couple very very cool
how old are you uh 32 31. she likes to
let me know she's 31. i like that four
months older than her
another month of it
robbing the cradle
nine years ago congratulations and happy
anniversary very well done got a copy of
the legacy journey for you and the total
money makeover as well
kyle and ally
atlanta georgia 105 000 paid off in 27
months one of the hardest working guys
we've run into in a while making 80 to
120 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
well done well done well done
absolutely fabulous
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you haven't heard uh two of our
ramsey personalities have brand new
books coming out both of them will be
national bestsellers
ken coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love is on sale right now including two
different bonus packs that you can
choose from either you want to get hired
or you want to get promoted
and you choose the appropriate bonus
pack it's about 200 worth of stuff when
you buy a 20 book from him and the same
situation for christy wright's new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance now this one's getting
ready to end because this book's getting
ready to come out september 13th is the
last day to pre-order so you got about a
week and a half two weeks to do this and
you get fifty to a hundred dollars worth
of bonus items when you pre-order the
book so you do wanna pre-order these
books because you get all these goodies
with it
for free
so here's an idea you could spend 40
bucks 20 on christy's book 20 on ken's
book and you'd get close to 500 worth of
stuff add it on there that's pretty
stinking incredible so you want to be
sure you get all that lined up and all
happening over at ramseysolutions.com
right this second ken coleman is my
co-host today doug is with us doug is in
tampa florida hi doug welcome to the
ramsey show
thanks steve
um i was going because a little
background story um i used to be an
addict and gambling
and uh i've gone ahead and been sober
for three years now good for you well
done how'd you do that
uh
well honestly lost everything
okay
it was uh kicked out of the house lost
car
uh kicked out of another house and so
that's kind of where i was leading to is
that how did you get did you get help
from somebody ga or what
no um actually my daughters or my fiance
now
i was
just by my side and said that you know
in order for us to keep a family
together and for me to be
to be around my daughter was either to
clean it up or
not be a part of her life and i couldn't
really see that in the future
so
um wow kind of a little ultimatum and
and uh so sucked it up and went on with
it so you've been dry three years
yep
um so i you know i was able to get the
finances back under control
uh start paying bills on time because
working was i was able to see the money
coming into the account i did you know i
have debt with the evictions and the
repos but no active debt no credit card
no student loans anything like that so
the reason i'm calling is because i back
to
the situation to where i'm not spending
money at a casino but i'm
you know i don't know where my money's
going i see the paychecks coming in by
the end of the week i'm
back down to the point to where i'm
getting scared where bills aren't going
to be paid on time
and i don't want to
relapse per se and get back into the
situation where i go make 3 400 real
quick just to pay the light bill yep
i like that so i like it i like it you
recognize the
the tightness in your chest and your
throat right
yes yeah that's smart that's wise okay
now uh
are your fiancee did you marry
oh we are getting married at the end of
the year okay well congratulations on
that okay so your character here's the
thing
i want you guys uh it sounds like you're
married or it sounds like you're living
together with a baby right yes okay
so um
you know as soon as you're married you
need to be sure you're doing this but
between now and then you can practice
working together
on the budget
okay so here's the thing the way you
stop living hand to mouth is three
things
obviously
if we lower expenses that helps
obviously if we increase our income that
helps but the most important thing is to
live on a plan
a written budget will make you feel like
you got a raise in your case
what it'll do is give you peace
right because right now money is a
stress point
it's a it's a it's a an area of great
anxiety
and uh me and my fiance yeah well i mean
she's scared she's scared you're gonna
do stupid again you're scared you're
just gonna twist out and not know what
to do and so here's the thing it's a
pretty simple idea but you have to do it
with a gr with great discipline and you
will a get tremendous peace from this
and b you're going to feel like you got
a raise
so here's how it works i want you i'm
gonna i'm gonna sign you up for
financial peace university to learn how
to handle money and in that you get
a uh for a year i'm gonna put you in the
ramsey plus for a year okay it's a
membership thing we're gonna put you in
there for a year in that you also get
our premium version of the world's best
budgeting app it's all free for you okay
it's called every dollar now the premise
of doing a budget is this the number of
dollars you have coming in this month
not a template
not the perfect month from heaven but
this month today is the first in
september what dollars are going to come
in you put those at the if you just draw
you know just to get a yellow pad and
put that number at the top of the page
and then i want you to give every and
that's you and your fiance i want you to
give every one of those dollars the two
of you working together to do this
an assignment
the first assignment that comes out of
that is food
the second one is lights and water
the third is you keep the transportation
rolling and the fourth is you pay the
rent
now if you've got all of that covered
and by the way you can
right then the rest of it is just kind
of monopoly
okay because once you know you have a
place to live and the light's not gonna
be cut off and you got food
your stomach relaxes
that tightness in your chest starts to
go down and you go and i still got
thousands of dollars laying here on this
pad i've got to figure out what to do
with and you give every one of those an
assignment and then oh by the way you
live by that once it's done
you don't spend money on anything
anywhere anytime unless it's on that
freaking paper
got it you're in charge of the budget
until it's done and then it's in charge
of you
you get to decide you get to decide
but then it tells you what to do
how would i go about the uh the
non-active debt
per se
uh worry about that after or that's the
last thing you deal with first thing we
deal with is get this crap out of your
life that's where it's all swimming
around in your head and about to blow
your it's about your head's about to
explode right
right we gotta get rid of that first but
then once you get past all of that then
way down the list is going to clean up
the past
okay and all you're gonna do there is i
you know with the exception of if
somebody's suing you or something i
would just list those debts smallest to
largest and i would look at the smallest
one and i would call that one and work a
deal with them
not a payment deal a lump sum deal
just pile up cash yep
eviction and what else
that's two two tenant evictions in a
repo that's it okay
so uh have any of them given you a
number
no i haven't gotten any judgments
nothing no no no no request for
collection no nothing
no i haven't and it's honestly been
three years i mean so i haven't i mean
so here's what's going to happen let's
say you call up landlord number one
and uh it was an apartment complex
corporate operation and they say we
added it all up and it's six thousand
dollars you say i can't do that but i do
have two thousand
okay they'll take it
okay may have to argue with them a
little bit but they'll take it you get
that in writing
in writing do not do it unless it's in
writing
and do not allow anyone to have
electronic access to your checking
account you give them a money order a
prepaid debit card or you give them cash
and get a receipt
okay perfect i don't care what it is a
certified check whatever but don't get
them don't let them get in your checking
account
because they'll clean you out
so each one of them are going to name a
number that's going to go like the repo
you can sell that repo for about 12
cents on the dollar
okay
and uh
it's just for the deficit is what they
sold the car for subtracted from the
balance plus they've added all kinds of
repo fees and legal fees to it you just
got to cut that back down and hey man
you're going to turn this around i can
tell you you're a guy that's you've
changed your life and now i get to be a
tiny bit of the back side of the story
so you hang on kelly i'll pick up and uh
ken and i are going to give you ramsey
plus
for a year which includes financial
peace university
and
every dollar the premium version a lot
of other things as well but coaches are
in there everything's in there pretty
cool
yeah he's gonna have a fun life yeah
all that pain is gonna turn into
something pretty passionate it's
exciting that much manure there's gotta
be a pony in there somewhere that's
right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today we're here to
help you with your life your money your
career ken coleman's show the ken
coleman show talks about jobs and
careers every day getting in work
that you love getting involved in work
that matters and we'll take calls about
that as well the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
chris is in san antonio texas
hi chris how are you
good afternoon guys hey what's up hi
dave so my question is or i guess yeah
my question
i have well i i became a landlord
about 22 years ago by default i have a
home in austin texas
i own it
but over that time that home has grown
significantly in value
so i'm at a point in my life where i
might want to sell at home
but i just need some direction in
knowing if
it's the right time for me to do that
and if i do decide to sell it i want to
know
if there's any way
to possibly avoid
capital gains tax
hmm
certainly a hot real estate market great
time to sell real estate
and by and large that's a general
statement right
um
capital gains um
you're going to pay capital gains on it
my guess is you've been depreciating it
all these years right
yes
so you probably have an adjusted basis
close to zero the whole thing may be
gained
well yes yes that's true yeah
and uh so what's the house worth
i think we could list it for about 550.
okay
yeah so you're going to have um
geez
you have
sixty thousand dollars in capital gains
right
yes that's that's no more than that more
than that ninety yeah
yeah okay but i i have a i have a stable
renter who pays on time um so he does a
lot of his home maintenance to the to
the property so
the situation right now is kind of ideal
but again i don't know if the market's
going to continue to increase or it's
going to
blow up and start you know declining in
value oh i think i think it's going to
go up in value i don't unless you've got
a neighborhood problem
but overall real estate i don't think
real estate has a category is going to
go down
certainly there are neighborhoods that
deteriorate you sometimes people let
their property deteriorate that kind of
thing but i'm not worried about that
part of it
the only thing i know that you can do to
avoid capital gains if you choose now is
the time to sell it for you
would be what's called a 1031 tax
deferred exchange and that would involve
tr would involve selling the property
into an escrow account and buying
another piece of real estate out of that
escrow account
and it is it is in effect a trade
as if you've traded this property for
another property and so you roll your
basis
into the new property uh and so if the
new property's 550 000 or less you're
gonna have zero basis in it
and uh and the new property so
you know you're not gonna have anything
you can depreciate
um unless you move up in
property and so you you mean you can buy
a million dollar property but obviously
you have to put up the money for the
difference
and so you're getting further into the
real estate business at that point and
it's just a matter of whether you want
to do that or not but for instance if
you wanted to buy four houses in san
antonio
um 150 000 houses you could do that
yeah and you know being a little you
know having them out there in your area
be able to spread them out and you just
roll you're just rolling the money over
from that's what a 1031 allows you to do
it's kind of like a rollover in the
sense you're rolling it from the
the austin house over there uh otherwise
you're just gonna be be paying a 15
capital gains rate
or more if you sell it next year biden's
talking about raising the cap rate
capital gains rate um so
um
i haven't looked at it lately dave uh i
thought that you uh didn't have to pay
on the first 500 000. that's personal
residence personal oh because this is a
rental i was going to rental more than
two of the last five years it is now a
rental
got it that experience loses that
exemption oh and he's had this in 22
years that's bad policy
hey i haven't owned any rental homes yet
so that was i'm a neophyte on that but
now that irritates me for you i'm glad
that's why i don't sell them so you
don't have to worry about it that is
true you don't you hold on to it hold
them but
that sets that bothers me yeah
well they um there's always a way to yes
raise taxes if you're a democrat i mean
that's just how it works so yes all
right melinda is with us melinda's in
richmond virginia hi melinda how are you
hi dave hi ken thanks for taking my call
i'm really excited to be talking to
y'all you too what's up
um so my husband and i we are about to
start baby step 456 and my question is
about how to hit that 15 towards our
retirement um my husband's base salary
is at 185
and um he gets an additional 30 to 35
000 in bonus in stock so we're kind of
finding that we're hitting that 19 500
uh 401k
contribution cap before we hit our 15
so i was hoping to kind of talk through
what we need to be doing to hit the rest
of our fifteen percent where can we be
putting that now you do a couple of
roths uh you're going to be over so you
have to do what's called a backdoor roth
but but uh okay um both of you do a roth
and that will just about get you there
that's going to be very close to your 15
the way a backdoor roth works is you get
with a smartvestor pro and they'll help
you get that going
but all you're doing is you open up an
after tax
ira
and then 20 seconds later you roll it to
a roth because it's an after-tax ira
you've already paid the taxes on the
money for it went in there just like you
would in a roth and so when you roll it
to a roth it has no tax effect
and um i do one every year and it's it's
the only way you can get money into a
uh an individual roth account if you
make more than 200 000
and you guys do with all this stuff
added up here so you're going to you're
going to bump into that ceiling but um
it's called a backdoor roth it's
actually technically i guess it's just a
loophole in the law
um
and uh but someday they'll they'll
button that one up i'm sure
um
never have gotten around to it so far um
well there's a lot of technicalities a
lot of reasons it's very hard to button
up but anyway aside from that yeah you
can just open an after tax and roll it
to a roth uh and you do that every year
and so
you know you'll have plenty of money
going in there then i think that and the
19 will get you there i think that'll
get you to where you need to be hey
thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
it is amazing the amount of
energy and brain power and dollars that
we spend
to get to keep our own money yes
flash two callers yeah yeah
yeah gotta jump through hoops to keep
the government
with is this a good investment it had
nothing to do with
the i'm able to get control of my money
it had to do with how do i keep the
government from taking my
money
it's a whole new idea
it's like a full-time job oh yeah we
call them accountants
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five we really value
the input of our listeners here to the
ramsey show it helps us know what's
important to you and we can adjust our
content delivery just what we're doing
here to make sure we're serving you
we've been doing this a long time but we
can always learn something from you guys
so if you want to take a survey a
listener survey of this show this
podcast
check out
ramseysolutions.com survey or text
survey to 33
789 there's 100
100 amazon gift card
that you will be in the drawing for if
you take this survey again visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey 233
789 we'd love to hear from you
nicholas is with us in miami hi nicholas
how are you of course how are you
hi there can you hear me absolutely
what's up
yeah you're gonna have to get off your
speaker phone or whatever you're doing
there get back on your regular phone
sorry about that that's right okay
that's what kelly told you okay how can
we help
so i have a question about the
inheritance so basically my dad has a
fairly peculiar relationship with his
family and he has like five five
siblings slash nephews that depend on
him fully financially
and i'm my only dad's son i'm fully
financially independent however he's
getting kind of old and i want him to
set up a will
to like um divide his state between me
and the people that depend on him
financially but he has not been willing
to do that why so like
basically whenever i bring a topic he
avoids it he tells me that he's gonna do
it sometimes and then he never does it
why and then
why why does he not do it
i don't know he's just like he doesn't
like to talk about money basically
how much money has he got i think
for like 2 million he states 10 million
to 2 million 2 million
well sometimes he used to talk about
money
unless he just fell into a pile of it
somewhere
i mean i think the problem is that
basically he's very
i would say very conservative like
he's very he doesn't want to give out
any information yeah he's cynical
there's
some shame about
his siblings he's still relying on him
financially basically yeah okay right so
do you know what his plan is you i mean
does he intend for the idea does he
intend for them to get the money
i have i have no idea basically and
uh like
he doesn't talk to me about himself
how old are you and he's
okay
uh i i hear some kind of accent that's
not southern what what's your accent
what's what's your family heritage i'm
i'm latino latino i'm not jamaican and
he is as well
yeah okay what country
columbia okay
all right and so he came here with
nothing
yeah and then he he made a significant
amount of money and he's 77 years old
now where do his siblings live are they
back in colombia are they in the states
they're uh they're back in colombia one
of them is in states and the other ones
are back in colombia okay all right
ken i i just want to know if you've ever
actually sat down with him and said uh
pretty plainly
very clearly hey dad you need to do
something about this and see if he's
actually going to react to you when you
do that or is it just something you're
kind of kicking the can around we're all
beating around the bush just curious
have you had a direct uh responsible
conversation about this
yeah like basically i think around last
year one of my uncles died because of
covert and at that point i'm like okay i
need to have this conversation i sat him
down i told him i want him to make
things clear what will happen with his
money
because i don't want to have that
problem be pushed to me or or to
basically
have to figure out what he wanted to do
once he's dead
he told me that he was going to make a
will and then nothing came out of that
yeah
so do you think
what would be your guess if he did do a
will
that it's going to say
you think he's gonna want you to manage
this money and take care of his brothers
and sisters
i i think that i think that's basically
what he actually wants me once wants to
happen do you wanna do that no interest
in doing it do you wanna do
no okay
all right
well the the only thing i know to do is
take another run at it and then you can
just wash your hands of it um and
another run would sound like this where
does he live
uh he he lives back in columbia at this
point oh he's in colombia as well okay
when will you be with him again do you
think
uh probably christmas
okay all right
so um what i would do is say this i i
would go ahead and let let's just not
have an abrupt uh conversation where we
hit a wall at christmas but go ahead and
start talking to him by phone now
and just say dad when i'm there
one of two things is going to occur
while i'm there and i need you to know
this because i love you
uh i want to i want you to help you
uh cause your wishes to be had
and uh you you so when i'm there i want
to see the will or you and i are going
to go meet with the attorney and the
will is going to occur and oh by the way
dad i'm not managing this money for your
siblings
so you need to have a different idea
i'm not willing to do that
i love you i don't need the money
and i and if you want to do that you can
set it up down there with a trust and so
forth but i'm not going to get sucked
into this where you've done business
poorly and you take up my life and i'm
also not going to get sucked into
managing the money for them for the rest
of my life these are not two things i'm
willing to do dad i love you i'll help
you any other way i can and if you want
to be responsible you need to get your
will done and i want to see it when i'm
there at christmas or i'll go with you
when we're there at christmas but it
does not need to say that i'm going to
manage the money for your siblings and
just say all of that on the phone
and just let him kind of get because my
guess is it take probably takes him a
little while to digest it
and uh you you uh grew up in a culture
like i did of honor
hillbillies and latinos share that
okay we're a culture of honor and so you
have to pay him honor
and yet you can honor him and not uh
abide by his wishes
it's possible
but that's just a matter it's just a
matter of telling him that you admire
what he does who he is you admire that
he's taking care of his siblings i'm not
willing to engage in that though dad and
i and i want to honor you upon your
death by making sure that your wishes
occur as long as it doesn't involve me
having to do that and and so you're
being sloppy with this dad and it's not
like you
you're a better businessman than this
and and
and i love you and i admire you so much
you're one of my heroes
that's how you pay honor did you hear it
yeah and that and am i right that he's a
man of honor
yeah i think though
nobody else takes care of their siblings
except people of honor
yeah there's a few that do but they're
just psychos
most people are just he sees that as an
act of honor that's why he does it
yeah
that's who he is as a person
so you need to you can you can
tip your hat to him
pay homage to who he is as a man what a
good person he is and he is a good
person
um and do all of that and yet not fall
into the trap of getting sucked into
managing a an estate with no will
nor get sucked into managing his money
for his brothers and sisters in
perpetuation and you can just lay those
out as boundaries in the discussion and
you can do that while paying him honor
and it's your only shot if he doesn't do
it then you just wash your hands of it
and just say dad i just love you but i'm
not doing it i'm not doing nothing when
you die
because i begged you to do this it's all
just going to melt down around their
heads down there
and um
you know you just turn up the heat on it
i don't know ken
no i think it's absolutely right i think
named dr john deloney we do yeah or he
needs to read henry cloud's uh uh
boundaries i mean i i think that you
nailed it you just have to put it in his
court he doesn't want to deal with he
doesn't want to talk about it so he kind
of acts like well it's just not there
and then you know honoring him and
respecting him is the way to go but also
forcing the issue yeah yeah you just got
to drive the nail home baby i mean and
i think you were right you're on to
something that
the problem is that the old man's just
being thick
and he's just going it's going to
require a little more direct punch in
the nose to get the thing moving yeah
but the only way to do that is with a
velvet glove that's true so
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
dead free stage chad and emmy lou are
with us hey guys how are you dave we're
so excited to be here welcome welcome
where do you guys live omaha omaha
nebraska and all the way to nashville
how much debt have you paid off 250 000
250
000
wow lots of loan interest and how long
did that take about three years three
years all right and your range of income
during that time like 123 to 141 123 to
141
okay
cool wow what kind of debt was the 250
student loans mostly
when we started the baby steps we had
about a little over 200 left on my
student loans okay and the rest hvac
windows deck wow
improvement yeah what do you guys do for
a living
i'm a dispatcher for a transportation
company and i'm a occupational therapist
in the home health setting all right
very cool what's your degree in that you
spent 200 grand for a clinical doctorate
okay all right good very pricey very
pricey yeah
yeah
so and you're making 141 how long y'all
been married
this is our seventh year
okay so after around four years of
marriage uh you begin this journey to
get out of debt what started you on the
journey
well that second little baby sitting
over there i was pregnant with her and
we well i went to daycare to pick up our
first and to reserve her a spot and i
knew how much daycare cost but walking
in hearing that number i mean i just had
a gut punch and we've always been frugal
we took your class when we were engaged
thank our thanks to our dad my dad and
i just knew i mean i just broke down in
tears i was pregnant i just knew we
could never pay off my loan debt with 20
000 in daycare every year and that was
just two kids and now we have three so
there's no way i mean we wouldn't have
made any progress i mean a thousand
extra a month goes nowhere when it's 36
dollars of interest a day yeah it was
crushing
we looked at our schedule and i worked
nights so i could watch the kids during
the day mostly and then she would switch
off so yeah our managers were just a
godsend we sat down and were like what
do we do
and my manager let me switch my day off
and he has a rotating schedule and so we
make it work i mean before covid
there were times when we met in the
driveway with the keys gave each other a
kiss and i mean we didn't see each other
all week
but now he gets to work from home at
least for now which is actually a
godsend so here we are yeah wow
very good you guys
so uh how does it feel to be free of 250
000 um it was a long three years yeah
it's a lot less crying um and more
traveling
we did our i mean we can get to this
later but we did our dream trip about
two weeks ago and took the kids to
disney
and you'll see in the picture
one of a picture of our kids at disney
and that just sums up our whole
experience i mean it's like living your
best life in one picture i mean i mean i
just cry and i'm just so excited
congratulations that's fun i'm glad you
celebrated we did go big
so talk about the intensity what was
what were some of the most intense
sacrifices i know the the the passing
ships in the night is certainly one of
them but some other sacrifices things
that were so difficult but also made
huge impact
um i think the biggest thing is uh this
guy right here you know dave talks about
being the man of the house and stepping
up and and being in charge and there are
days that he doesn't get any sleep you
know we have three kids and i leave
sometimes for work at six or seven in
the morning
and that's the big sacrifice is him i
mean he's done it all for me i mean two
hundred thousand that's a lot in student
loans to yeah we just put in two in
order to get it done so whatever
sacrifice we can um i mean we sell stuff
we uh we live very frugally i mean
nebraska is a low cost of living but you
know we didn't eat out we didn't travel
i mean we were gazelle i mean if you
have a definition of gazelle we were it
um i mean we didn't sacrifice on some
things like pictures our family pictures
is the most important thing to me but
other than that i mean
that's it i mean our clothes we
consignment sales you know we just did
it all we were so motivated what's the
thing that you may never eat again
oh is there is there a meal you ate too
much that was like broke people food and
you never eat you know she is the best
cook ever oh
i love it that's good i think this guy's
got a superman cape back there oh
seriously pretty incredible yeah yeah
you're making the rest of us look bad
dude yeah seriously stop
well done you guys very well done that's
cool okay what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is because
you've done a lot here
yeah um
having goals and attaining them was a
big thing you know i mean we had that
ultimate the large goal of three years
of
working to pay off this debt but little
goals in between you know we can get
this loan done and then this one and
that's you know just attaining each goal
and for me it was just um having an end
goal in sight you know when the kids are
little this is the time to do it we
realize like as they get older there's
only more activities to do
more things to get involved with and
more opportunities and when they're
babies let's face it you don't want to
travel anyway it's so hard so we did it
you know we're like let's do it now
we're having our kids now and then we're
going to be free forever i mean we have
we have two years left on our house and
then we're done i mean we're wow we're
living it it's it's so great thanks to
you i'm so proud of y'all well done
you're heroes
very well done great job yes it's good
stuff very good stuff and so you brought
the kiddos with you what are their names
and ages yeah um we have elliott he's
four we have kinsley who's three or two
two years two and a half come here buddy
bryn lee who will be she's our sweet
baby girl she's almost here
that is dave ramsey you're right you're
like are we going to see the real deal
ramsey yeah he watches on tv all the
time digital version
oh come here baby we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you it's obviously
obvious that you have a great legacy uh
it's a beautiful thing you've done i'm
so proud of y'all and a copy of the
total money makeover as well the total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody and help them start their
journey chad and emmy lou elliott
kinsley and brindley omaha nebraska 250
000 paid off in three years making 123
to 141 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
[Music]
yeah
love it love it love it so well done
beautiful job man
the uh schedule thing with the daycare
is that's enormous yeah brutal so now
it's an amazing amount of money oh yeah
that that we know that the daycare costs
to get you know in most places
you have to make serious money just to
work absolutely right yeah i mean and
she struggled you know you think about
how much schooling she went through
she's got her doctorate she she does
some really important in-home work you
know that's life-changing for the
families that she's engaging with i mean
and to see how they're working together
um the sacrifice uh and you know what
way to go chat i mean that's some
serious props from your wife man and and
that's uh that's next level conviction
that we talk about we talk about gazelle
intensity it's got to come from
somewhere that intensity cannot be
manufactured you know that it comes from
a deep searing
you know conviction that this must be
sick and tired i'm not gonna live like
this i've had it i'm not living like
this anymore and you've got you've got
to reach that point earl nightingale
used to say that it's not what you're
willing to do
to achieve your goals it's what you're
willing to give up yes
to achieve your goals sleep yeah i mean
we've had two debt-free callers on the
show today both of which worked
unbelievable hours yeah
and uh well i don't want to be a
workaholic you're not a workaholic honey
workaholic is when you get your
is when you you get your satisfaction
from work so you do nothing else it's
like you're addicted to work yeah that's
a workaholic working hard everyone that
works hard is not a workaholic
somebody's working hard simply as a goal
they're trying to hit they're living
like no one else so later they can live
and give like no one else i've worked
like no one else for 25 30 years now i
work when i want to
um i want to be down here and do this
show and that's why i do it every day
but uh it's it's a decision now you know
when you do what they've done now they
get choices you get margin you get
wiggle room and it gives you choices and
you don't have to be you don't have to
be working for a jerk you don't have to
be in a stuck in a a bad job amen to
that toxic situation
changes everything
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day isaiah 25 1
lord you are my god i will exalt you and
praise your name for in perfect
faithfulness you have done wonderful
things things planned long ago
michael jordan said some people want it
to happen some wish it would happen
others
make it happen
there it is and he certainly did does
that kind of thing
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
q is with us in nashville hi q how are
you
okay so
okay you're gonna have to get off the
speakerphone kiddo
hello yeah there you go like kelly told
you to okay
you there
you're gone all right up next is weston
and uh salt lake city utah hi weston how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
hi so my work gave me um
two phantom unit award agreements and i
was wondering if you could
explain what those are and
uh yeah i just was searching and i've
never seen you talk about them on your
youtube channel or
however so no i probably haven't but uh
i mean basically it's deferred comp is
what it is based on the stock price
and
there's not a set necessary there's not
a necessarily a set methodology on when
you receive them it would be by the
agreement
a lot of them they give you own they
only let you cash them in when you leave
is that what yours are
i believe so um
yeah they ended up giving me
1250 units and yeah both of them have
different like grant dates and investing
commencement dates and
yeah and i just
i
have a vague understanding of what they
are and i just uh well it's it's not
actually stock stock is you actually own
a portion of a company
an equity position it's called a phantom
unit is it's um
it's a ghost obviously so but what it
does is it replicates the real thing and
so
uh if you have 1200 units and um
they're worth a dollar a piece then
they're then if stock is selling for a
buck a share then it's twelve hundred
dollars if it's down for ten dollars a
share it's twelve thousand a share
twelve thousand dollars um if it's
selling for a hundred dollars a share be
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars so
um you know your
units are worth what the stock price is
per share of stock
and then when you can cash them in is
unique to each
company and each agreement and it sounds
like you have a vesting schedule which
means that's when you
actually become the owner and then what
you'd have to determine other than that
from the vesting schedule or from
hr can probably tell you this or maybe
your agreement if you read through it
after you're vested can you cash them or
do you have to wait till you leave after
you're vested
vested means they actually are yours for
the first time
um
in a sense you become an owner of the
phantom units which is kind of an
oxymoron but you know but you know it's
their the valuation is the price the
stock price times the number of units
that's what it's worth
and then how you can get to them the
schedule of access to the money is
unique to each agreement
so good question thanks for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five daniel is with us
daniel's in nashville hi daniel how are
you
i'm good dave i got a question about
i i get
disability from the va
on top of my working and i work for the
state of tennessee and so i get i get
the retirement through the state
uh with the pension how do i
how do i
make
the
math work on
when i realized i'm going to be
receiving this
disability until i die
and how do i do am i making sense how am
i
calculating this so that i am set for
retirement uh right now i have um
about 150 000 in retirement
um
right now i'm putting 1300 a month into
my 401k
uh even though this gun i'm full pension
i don't get any match from the state on
that but i'm also maxing out my ira
every year at six thousand dollars good
good um well you've got that nest egg
and you the two the nest egg from the
401k and the nest egg from the iras and
that's money that you actually control
you control what what is is invested in
you control when you take it out
at retirement whether you take it out at
retirement you can let it sit there and
grow
you can move it to when you retire you
could roll that 401k into an ira at that
time in mutual funds and you can have
complete control of that part of your
world and that's your nest egg so if
that nest egg is sitting down with your
investment professional with your
smartvistor pro is going to grow to
i'll just make up a number a million
dollars all right
so you know you've got that nest that
million dollars is going to create an
income and
you've got the va income thank you for
your service
and you've got the state pension coming
and those are your three
items that are that are there they they
are different ones coming from the feds
one's coming from the state um and one
is coming from your hard work sweat and
saving
uh and the one that you have the most
control over is that last one
the other the other two okay
hypothetically could get messed up i'm
i'm not predicting they're gonna get
messed up state of tennessee's run very
well uh if you were in another state i
might be a little bit more worried about
your the quality of your pension
but uh some states are run well some
aren't
but the state of tennessee's business
has done pretty well we've had several
consecutive good governors in terms of
their uh
the way they conduct the uh the business
of the states i think you're the
pension's in plenty good shape
uh and i'm not worried about that and
i'm not predicting the federal
government's gonna cave in either so i
think you're gonna get both of those but
they're just an income
and they die with you
right okay
all right thank you so much dave hey
thank you appreciate you joining us
open for the thing you don't want to do
ken in that and i probably should have
brought that up while i still hit him on
the line um the thing you don't want to
do is count only on those yes that is
correct because you don't have
flexibility then right yeah and you
don't have control no control yeah no
options he's in really good shape uh
yeah he's doing great because he's
saving like a maniac like crazy i mean
really pouring into his 401k he's got
the retirement nest egg so he's gonna be
in great shape yeah heading in the right
way alec is with us alec is in pensacola
how are you alec
i'm great how are you doing better than
i deserve what's up
hey i'd love to hear that
all right so my fiance and i are about
to get married
i am in the military and she is fresh
out of college for a nursing degree
that is going to put us together fifty
five thousand five hundred dollars in
school debt
two credit cards totaling fifty five
hundred
and then two found the ones on my part
to pay off my car totaling in fourteen
thousand the car's worth
twenty
25
and
total income for myself is about 42 and
obviously we don't know
how much she's going to make yet until
she
finds a job we're assuming it's going to
be between 30 and 50k
and
you know
that's a combined income of maybe 85k
with the total debt of 75k
and we're really really really trying to
rice and beans that
get this debt paid off good for you i
did i didn't know you know the best way
to go about that and how fast we could
assume to maybe pay that off well very
good well i mean if you did 35 a year
you'd be done in two years
and do you think 35 a year is attainable
that's truly beans and rice making 80.
and it might involve selling 25 000 car
too
yes
okay i'd really consider that alec
that's a that's a big big jump start to
what you're doing
that car's worth you gotta you know that
car is gonna continue continue to go
down in value and right now we're seeing
the highest uh rates for used cars that
we've ever seen i would move on that you
can make some big big big progress there
yeah
okay
that's probably not gonna be a real
popular decision if that's the first
thing out of your mouth so i wouldn't
lead with that
that's true too but uh but but i i think
you can do this i think it's very doable
what i'll do is this i want to say thank
you for serving your country and i want
to give you a wedding gift we're going
to put you into financial peace
university which includes uh
a one-year membership to ramsey plus
that'll get you signed up for it we're
going to give that to you as our gift
you guys go through that class together
uh as you're doing your premarital
counseling and uh that'll that the two
of you together will make really really
good decisions and the two of you
together will decide to say how deeply
you want to sacrifice there for how fast
you want to get out that's how this deal
works
so very cool man very cool again thanks
for serving ken coleman good job ben and
kelly in the booth good work i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you